I respect the hell out of a cold [__] I
mean my God my grandmother uh I just
learned finessed me out of like sixty
thousand dollars [__] yeah and I was
like that is some old school as Luis
Gomez would say real ass dude of the
week
dude I'm talking about from the Great
Depression from Oklahoma yeah you know
like this woman
95 about to be 96 broken hip would not
let me so for 12 or 13 years I've been
giving her money I've been giving her
about 1500 a month yeah because she told
me all I have is Social Security she
lives in a very poor county in
California right she's like I need money
without you I wouldn't pay my bills
without you I wouldn't have food so I
gave her money and I was like I love you
and then I'd always be like why don't
you add me on the bank account why don't
you have me on the bank account so I can
deposit the money a little bit easier
and she's like don't worry about it I
got it I got it
would keep sending her money and then
she fell and broke her hip and she had
to go to a facility she's 95 and so
she's getting rehabbed and I had to get
her enrolled for Medi-Cal I had to like
start like looking into it and I was
like hey I need to get onto your bank
account and she was like I don't know
and then her neighbor was like you know
I knew her neighbor was on the bank
account and I was like hey
can you give me this information that I
need and he's like yeah I also just want
to tell you real quick about seven years
ago your grandmother was like well I
can't put Dan on the bank account
because if he finds out what's in my
bank account he'll stop sending me money
great and I was like oh that's [__] up
amazing and then I'm I'm getting all the
information and then her neighbor calls
me and he's like
all right I got the bank it gives me the
bank the numbers of the bank accounts
and he says in savings she has seven
thousand dollars I was like oh my God
yeah that's way more than I thought she
had right and he goes well
in checking she has sixty two thousand
dollars and I was like
and she's underwater on her mortgage but
she's got the money
but because
Medi-Cal they do like a five-year check
of finances audit yeah they do an audit
I can't take that money out yeah she got
you got me she got me so now I'm paying
you now I'm paying will you confront her
on the air
if we could get a hold of her I'll just
go in there with cameras just her with
her seven on your side
danger Buster Mike Russ is it true you
had this and she's like
uh dude she would do small stuff that my
fiance was like dude she's she's
mentally [__] she would call me by my
dead father's name yeah yeah I'm not
Gary and she's like okay I was like this
[__] she really was it was like she's
farting she's good it was like Spartan
training she knows how to do it she was
like let go of your emotions you [__]
yeah she knows how to do it but it was
wild when I found that out I was like
you know what I'm kind of impressed with
the hustle yeah of course you have to
respect it